Resuelve para "y" y tenemos
3y más 7 menor que 2y
y también se debe cumplir
que 4y más 8 sea mayor que -48.
Entonces nuestra variable "y"
debe satisfacer esta desigualdad
y también la del lado derecho,
debe satisfacer ambas,
y para poder resolver eso
como hemos estado haciendo,
los separamos en dos problemas aparte
y vemos cuál es el conjunto de valores
que cumplen ambos.
Muy bien,
entonces vamos a tomarnos
3y más 7 menor que 2y
y para ir despejando la "y",  lo que podemos es
restar 2y de ambos lados
para que del lado derecho,
para que todas las "y"
queden de lado izquierdo esencialmente.
Entonces del lado izquierdo tenemos
3y menos 2y es "y" más 7
y esto debe ser menor que
2y menos 2y que es 0,
así que tenemos finalmente
"y" más 7 es menor que 0.
Ya finalmente para despejar la "y" podemos simplemente restar 7 de ambos lados...
restamos 7 de ambos lados,
ok, y entonces me queda
7 menos 7 se cancelan,
ese es el punto de restar 7,
y me queda del lado izquierdo
"y" menor que es 0 menos 7 que es
-7
Muy bien,
aquí tenemos nuestra primera restricción
que nos impone el problema
y ahora vamos a ver qué ocurre con la segunda,
es decir,
¿qué ocurre con esta desigualdad?
Muy bien, entonces tenemos,
4y más 8 es mayor que -48.
Entonces lo primero que a mí se me ocurre
es restar 8 de ambos lados...
restamos 8 de ambos lados,
restamos 8
y lo que me queda es que esto se cancela por supuesto,
y tenemos
4y
es mayor que...
-48 menos 8 son de signos iguales, entonces en realidad sumamos los números y le dejamos el signo,
y es 48 más 8 son 56.
Muy bien.
Entonces lo siguiente es
dividir todo entre 4,
dividir ambos lados entre 4,
que no me afecta la desigualdad
porque 4 es positivo y sólo se cambia cuando
dividimos o multiplicamos por algo negativo,
así que en este caso no pasa nada,
estos cuatro se cancelan,
y me queda que "y" es mayor que -56 entre 4,
entonces da menos,
56 entre 4,
bueno 4 por 10 son 40
y 4 por 4 son 16,
así que son 14 ¿verdad?.
Es "-y"...
bueno 56 entre 4 es 14,
4 por 4, 16 y llevamos 1
4 y 1...
4 por 1 = 4  y 1 son 5, muy bien,
entonces "y" es mayor que -14
pero no hay que perder de vista
que se debe cumplir ambos.
Mejor lo ponemos con mayúscula,
así
se debe cumplir que "y"
es menor que -7,
y al mismo tiempo que
"y" debe ser mayor que -14
Muy bien.
Entonces
¿Cómo se graficaría esto?
Esto si lo ponemos
en la recta numérica,
digamos aquí esta nuestra recta numérica,
quizás por ejemplo aquí está el -7
- 8, -9, -10, -11, -12, -13 y -14
aquí está el -14,
no sé, quizás acá es
-6, -5, - 4, - 3, - 2, -1, 0,
aquí anda el 0, pero bueno,
ya no nos interesan los demás,
entonces,
el amarillo, la solución amarilla
me dice que "y" debe ser menor que -7,
entonces el -7 no lo incluimos
y nos vamos
hacia la izquierda
y nos podemos seguir
tanto como queramos hacia la izquierda ¿verdad?
Sin embargo
tenemos otra restricción,
la restricción morada que me dice que
debe ser más grande que -14,
no puede ser 14,
entonces nos vamos hacia la derecha,
y nos seguiríamos hasta la derecha
excepto que no podemos pasar de -7
¿verdad?
No podemos pasar de -7,
y finalmente nuestro conjunto solución
es justamente éste,
este conjunto en que va de -14 a -7.
Muy bien.
Ese es nuestro conjunto solución, así que ya nada más para terminar y estar bastante cómodos
con nuestra respuesta, vamos a intentar algunos,
por ejemplo,
¿Qué tal si nos tomamos algo por aquí,
-8, -9?
Mira por ejemplo este que es el -10
¿ok? si sustituimos -10 como se encuentra en el conjunto solución,
debe cumplir ambas,
ambas desigualdades.
Vamos a ver,
3 por -10 más 7
debe ser menor que,
2 por -10
y 3 por -10 son -30 más 7,
es menor que
-20 y -30 más 7 son -23
que claramente es -20 ¿verdad?
Este es mucho más negativo que -20.
¡A ver! Vamos a intentar alguno que no,
que no funcione
¡Ah! pero espera,
antes tenemos que ver
que cumple también la otra.
4 por -10 más 8
¿será cierto que es mayor que -48?
4 por -10 más 8 es,
debe ser mayor que -48,
ok, 4 por -10 es -40
más 8 debe ser mayor que -48
y -40 más 8 son -32,
que sí es cierto
que es más grande que -48,
es menos negativo
¿verdad?
Y si nos damos cuenta, por ejemplo el 0,
el 0 si lo sustituimos,
aquí tenemos 3 por 0 más 7 pues son 7,
que debe ser menor que
2 por 0, que es 0,
y no es cierto que
7 sea menor que 0,
entonces 0,
la que no cumple es esta desigualdad
si por ejemplo nos tomáramos aquí -15,
la que no va a cumplir
es la desigualdad de la derecha.
¿Ok? Entonces espero
que esto haya sido bastante útil.